So let's look at how
the processor sees the memory.
The processor sees what we call,
physical memory, which is the memory
contained in the actual memory modules,
that we bought and put in the system.
The amount of that memory sometimes,
even lower, than 4GB.
It is almost never 4GB per process that
we have in the system, because there
can be tens or even hundreds of
processes in a modern operating system.
And it is never 16 exabytes per process.
This is how much memory we need, if we
have 2 to the 64th memory locations,
which is what you would
have with a 64-bit address.
So if each process in a 64-bit machine
thinks it has this much memory,
there is just no way we can have
enough actual memory for that.
So we conclude that the amount
of physical memory we have
is usually less than what
all the programs can access.
If all the programs access all
the memory they possibly can,
they will access much, much more
than the memory we actually have.
The addresses that the processor
uses for the physical memory
have a one to one mapping to the bytes
or words in the physical memory.
So a given address always goes
to the same physical location.
And the physical location always
has exactly one physical address.